salut les épis curieuse et les épis
curieux aujourd'hui je vous parle d'un
appareil qu'on utilise tous je vous le
dis en anglais zaiko owens waze vague en
français le micro-ondes idéal pour
transformer les grains de maïs en pop
corn est ce que c'est bon pour la santé
peut-on tout mettre dedans je suis chaud
pour vous expliquer tout ça
comme beaucoup d'objets du quotidien le
micro-ondes que l'on trouve dans nos
cuisines a été inventé par hasard c'est
aussi le cas des post it ou du velcro
mais ça je vous l'expliquais dans une
autre vidéo
revenons au micro à la fin de la seconde
guerre mondiale percy spencer un
ingénieur américain travaille sur le
nouveau modèle d'un appareil appelé le
magnétron rien à voir avec la cuisine à
l'époque le magnétron est un élément
utilisé dans les radars pour mieux
repérer les avions en plein vol grâce à
des zones ultra cool selon la légende un
jour alors qu'il a un petit creux et
qu'il retire de sa poche une barre
chocolatée
le scientifique constate qu'elle a fondu
il a alors une idée pailhas et des
grains de maïs
devant le magnéto et la stupéfaction
il fait des pop corn hot
c'est ainsi que le four à micro-ondes
aînés
le premier modèle mis en vente est
baptisé radar anges et franchement il
n'est pas hyper pratique il faut avoir
une grande cuisine puisqu'il mesure 1
mètre 80 et pèse plus de 300 kg vous
imaginez aussi volumineux qu'un gros
réfrigérateur et le poids d'un cheval se
le procurer il fallait alors débourser
entre 2 et 3000 $ c'est l'équivalent
aujourd'hui de 30 mille dollars alors
forcément au début le micro ondes et
micro utilisé seulement dans les
cantines militaires et les hôpitaux et
au milieu des années 1950 que l'appareil
commence à faire son entrée dans les
foyers américains en europe il faudra
attendre les années 70 pour que les
premiers micro ondes soit adoptée par
les ménages et encore pas tous à
l'époque c'est un produit de luxe il
coûtait jusqu'à 6000 francs autrement
dit by fois le salaire mensuel minimum
puis avec l'engouement des plats
préparés dans les années 80 et 90 et les
progrès de la technologie son prix
baisse et le micro-ondes devient peu à
peu un incontournable des cuisines
aujourd'hui selon l'insee 90% des foyers
français en possèdent un et s'il s'est
modernisé le principe reste le même
c'est celui d'une magnétron magnétron
c'est un personnage de science-fiction
sa main non c'est pas de la fiction
c'est de la science tout court
les micro ondes et je ne parle pas de
l'objet sont des ondes
électromagnétiques
elles sont de la même nature que la
lumière émise par une ampoule mais comme
les infrarouges ou les ultraviolets
elles sont invisibles elles font
également partie de la même famille que
les ondes utilisées par la radio les
vieilles télévisions et même le wifi
comme toutes les ondes elles sont
caractérisées par leur fréquence est à
dire le nombre d'oscillations en une
seconde cette fréquence se mesure en
herbe les micro-ondes aussi la une
fréquence de
2450 mégahertz j'ai bien dit mega
autrement dit elles oscillent
2450 millions de fois par seconde ah oui
ça bouge sacré bon quand même oui ça
bouge beaucoup et en contrepartie les
ondes sont extrêmement courts fréquences
élevées ont une très courte c'est ça le
secret allez en cuisine quand on met un
plat au micro ondes les aliments sont
bombardés d'ondés électromagnétiques qui
les traversent et en les traversant les
molécules d'eau contenue dans les
aliments se mettent à bouger elle se
cognent les unes aux autres bref elles
se mettent elles aussi à osciller est
sacrément vite au même rythme que les
hommes c'est ce mouvement cette
agitation qui produit de l'énergie et de
la chaleur le même phénomène se produit
lorsqu on se frotte les mains
ça chauffe mais revenons au popcorn les
grains de maïs contiennent de l'eau des
lipides et de laninon sous l'effet des
micro ondes les molécules d'eau s'agite
de la température monte l'eau se
transforme en vapeur elle occupe un plus
grand volume de l'eau liquide la
pression monte l'amidon est repoussé à
la périphérie et devient vice que
jusqu'au moment où la pression est trop
forte l'enveloppent éclate l'amidon est
projeté à l'extérieur et tout cela va
très vite moins de deux minutes
seulement au passage c'est pour la même
raison que certains récipient explose
quand vous les mettez au micro ondes en
général ils contiennent des plats dont
les aliments contiennent beaucoup d'eau
et dans le récipient est fermée
hermétiquement
ça nous est tous arrivé l'eau se
transforme en vapeur fait pression et le
couvercle fini par sauter d'où la
nécessité d'autres ouvrir le couvercle
ou de le percer lorsqu'il s'agit d'un
film plastique ce qui permet à la vapeur
de s'échapper moi ce qui m'inquiète
c'est le rayonnement c'est pas un peu
dangereux pour la santé en cas de
contact direct avec la peau oui le
rayonnement peut être nocif et provoquer
des brûlures mais pas de panique
lorsqu'il est en marche et que la porte
fermée le rayonnement reste confinée à
l'intérieur de l'appareil je vous
montrais
une grille très serré que l'on voit à
travers la porte tendu dessus
l'empêchent de passer l'enfant dufour
quant à elle forme une cage métallique
qui piège les micro ondes on appelle ça
une cage de faraday métallique et j'ai
entendu dire que micro ondes et métal ça
ne faisait pas bon ménage en fait les
parois du four reflète les micro ondes
qui se propage dans l'appareil il est
conçu pour ça il ne faut jamais y mettre
d'objets métalliques qui ont des bords
saillants une boîte de conserve par
exemple une cuillère ou une fourchette
ou même une assiette ou une tasse avec
des dorures ces objets ne contiennent
pas d'eau l'énergie des micro-ondes
n'est pas absorbée en revanche elle met
en mouvement les électrons contenus dans
le métal qui s'accumulent au niveau des
angles au niveau des pointes c'est ce
qu'on appelle d'ailleurs on les fait de
pointe quand il y en a trop la tension
provoque une décharge un arc électrique
un petit éclair si vous préférez et ça
ça peut être dangereux pour éviter de
prendre des risques moi je n'utilise que
des contenants en plastique fins il y à
plastiqué plastique que j'explique
sous l'effet de la chaleur certains
peuvent libérer des substances toxiques
ce serait le cas par exemple du
bisphénol a reconnu comme un
perturbateur endocrinien
s'il est désormais interdit à la vente
en france certaines boîtes en plastique
qui en contiennent sont toujours en
circulation un conseil donc débarrassez
vous des vieux récipients en plastique
qui traînent dans vos placards en fait
un logo figure sur les boîtes en
plastique qui sont compatibles avec les
micro ondes et puis si vous avez un
doute le mieux c'est d'utiliser un plat
en verre ou en céramique ça marche même
avec le carton moi j'ai entendu dire que
les micro-ondes pouvait contaminer les
aliments alors soyons clairs
non une fois chauffé votre nourriture ne
devient pas
radioactives en plus les micro-ondes
permettent de préserver les nutriments
contenus dans les aliments un peu comme
la cuisson à la vapeur utilisé
correctement le micro on est donc un
moyen sûr et sain de cuisine et
je crois que mon petit plat est prêt
merci d'avoir regardé cette vidéo si
elle vous a plu vous pouvez mettre un
pouce bleus et vous abonner à la chaîne
c'est juste en dessous moi aller à très
très vite cher épi curieuse epicurium
pourquoi la fondue fait tel défi eh bien
j'y réponds et encore plus de questions
dans ce petit livre réalisé en
partenariat avec nathan vous y
retrouverez également un quiz et un test
savoir quel fromage vous êtes
personnellement je suis roquefort avis
aux fondus de lecture l'avenir est ici
[Applaudissements]